adam la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues
43 degrés à biarritz le 18 juin 51
degrés à jacobabad le 14 mai le 14 mai
au pakistan chaque année nous
connaissons de nouveaux records de
température d'action humaine notre
action modifie le climat met en péril le
vivant nous sommes entrés dans l'ère de
l'anthropocène il n'y a plus de rage
mais des tempêtes plus d'épisodes
pluvieux mais des inondations les
sinistres succèdent aux catastrophes les
classes ferme ta gueule face aux vagues
de chaleur ici comme ailleurs
régulièrement les récoltes sont perdues
les bâtiments détruits les routes
défoncées les arbres arrachés et bien
souvent il ya des morts pourtant nous
savions depuis longtemps en 1971 total
en terre un rapport sur l'impact de ses
activités sur les réchauffements
climatiques en 1984 le rapport met dos
explique pour la première fois qu'une
croissance infinie dans un monde fini
n'a pas de sens
depuis 1988 les experts du giec alerte
les gouvernements nous ne faisons rien
disons le clairement la transition
écologique n'est toujours pas le coeur
des politiques publiques je vous le dis
plus clairement encore madame la
première ministre votre projet à 50 ans
de retard il est tout droit sorti des
années 70 la période où la croissance
la technologie et l'énergie infinie
devait résoudre tous les problèmes en
cinq ans la situation s'est dégradée il
est là votre bilan la certitude que
faute d'une action déterminée faute de
choix clair et assumé faute d'un budget
à la hauteur la france trahi les
engagements de la coop 21 dont nous
étions si fiers
pourquoi cette inaction parce que
certains se pense à l'abri croient
encore que l'argent leurs traits mais de
s'adapter de créer une bulle de confort
illusion paré pour l'effort par et pour
les puissants pourquoi cet attentisme
parce que les premières victimes du
dérèglement climatique sont les plus
pauvres les plus vulnérables ceux qui ne
vivent pas au bon endroit
elle qu'on entend rarement qu'on ne veut
pas écouter qu'on ne voit pas ce qui
croule sous les factures sous les
contraintes et sous l'inflation c'est
elle qui tiennent aux hôpitaux à bout de
bras quand elle fait face à une pandémie
n'est de la destruction des milieux
naturels
pourquoi cet immobilisme parce que
l'écologie madame la première ministre
est une promesse de campagne sitôt trahi
au lendemain des élections
pour affronter la crise climatique il
faudra compter les inégalités
territoriales
vous en avez parlé madame la première
ministre mais comment vous croire chez
moi en isère la montagne s'écroule les
glaciers disparaissent les étés sont
irrespirable à la luire à la vie de neuf
mois renault dit on étouffe sur les
dalles l'été et on gèle l'hiver dans les
passoires thermiques pour affronter
l'effondrement du vivant il faut oser
remettre en cause un modèle économique
l'idée par une idéologie productiviste
extractiviste est destructrice las nubes
est une union des forces parce que pour
nous il est évident que la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique est un combat
pour la justice sociale
lorsqu'on est comptable d'un bilan tels
que le voc madame la première ministre
je comprends que vous ne vous soumettiez
pas un vote de confiance car la
confiance d'un second quinquennat se
construit et se délite sur l'épreuve
laissé par le précédent
l'épreuve ne joue pas en votre faveur
la réforme de l'assurance chômage un
recul social la baisse des apl une
ponction directe chez nos bailleurs
sociaux l'enterrement de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat une erreur
historique
pensez vous vraiment qu'il suffira de
quelques événements ce pour que notre
pays aille mieux quand c'est tout un
système qui broie des vies entières les
français les françaises n'y crois pas
écoutez les les gilets jaunes et les
marches pour le climat ont convergé pour
nous rappeler que la fin du monde la fin
du mois sont un seul et même combat
les électeurs et les électrices ont fait
un choix le choix de vous imposer dans
les urnes la proportionnelle que vous
leur aviez promis sont jamais là leurs
données ils ont eu raison ils ont eu
raison avant de l'institution ils ont eu
raison avant un personnel politique
fossilisé dans son présidentialisme ce
vote vous oblige madame la première
ministre après nous avoir expliqué ils
vous obligent à écouter à écouter
l'assemblée nationale à écouter le
peuple n'ayez pas peur de l'année où
cratie n'ayez pas peur de cette
assemblée faites confiance aux français
et aux françaises qui portait déjà les
prémices ils n'ont pas fonction vivent
une oie prétention au monde et aux
autres tu es cette assemblée soit c'est
l'outil seront des chemins pour une
nouvelle sensibilité aux vivants pour
l'émancipation de chacun et de chacune
et pour conserver l'habitabilité de
notre terre merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]